[Music]
hey you guys happy sunday yeah we had a
little uh delay there about 10 minutes
had to reset the router holy [ __ ]
couldn't get the [ __ ] streaming right
now nothing works it's going slow it was
just the router needed to be reset
that's not a big deal just that it takes
a long time for it to go through the
reset cycle that's what i mean it's like
every god man i don't know if it's just
the internet here or the computers or
whatever everything's like grandpa speed
it's it's a mixture of everything holy
[ __ ] just missed your picture pull my
[ __ ] hair out
it's just how it is
yeah it's slow well we don't have that
[ __ ] really good high-speed internet
cable company that we had at the last
place yeah i know that place was that
that was a good cam that was a good
company what was the name of that
company again
uh
well we had a t and t for a while yeah i
thought i've changed i i changed it a
couple times during the time that we
were there but i had that [ __ ] set up on
autopay i forgot which one it was
i think i think it was at t
yeah zach said jenny you look good with
your hair down thank you yeah yeah i had
it up earlier but then i thought oh yeah
yeah he's looking kind of messy so i
just like write it down
yeah we're finally
pull tom's hair out instead
pull tom's air out instead yeah i could
just go because she snaps on me you know
she
she
what the [ __ ] was that
damn train
i guess it was the semi horn or
something it was one of the [ __ ]
rednecks with his monster truck knock it
off he has a [ __ ] train horn well i
get mad at you because you because you
say like really obvious things like i
didn't already think of that yeah you
know what i mean
have you tried like turning it off and
turning it back on i'm like yeah
[Laughter]
i know how computers work
[Laughter]
but yeah so remember like last week we
said that we were going to
do midnight cowboy because we watched it
last week and then we just didn't get
around to it because we didn't do
matinee we did other movies and various
other things so finally today we're
finally getting around to talking about
it god damn it yeah midnight cowboy and
this like i said we got into this whole
we went off on this whole 70s thing
really just because we because we talked
about that movie the believers from 87
which was john schlesinger and uh then
we were kind of like oh we should watch
like midnight cowboy we should watch
this other thing and then we've just
been watching [ __ ] 70s movies 70s
just [ __ ] delivering out the wazoo we
watched uh eyes of laura mars last night
that [ __ ] was off the chain we'll
have to yeah you've never seen that
i saw that star cast i had i had seen
that a bunch of times uh when i was
younger and i hadn't seen it in a long
time
um [ __ ] what's his name tommy [ __ ]
was it time tommy lee jones was in it i
didn't know he was in it
oh [ __ ] dude to play gomez was in it
[ __ ] damn well julia yeah yeah um
yes we'll talk about that tomorrow
probably
uh also last night we watched
uh prisoners of the ghost land that knew
nicholas cage movie yeah didn't love it
no um
visually cool but i just i don't know i
couldn't get into it it just kind of rip
off of uh into the badlands that series
you know it was playing after uh
uh [ __ ] walking dead which i never
got into i never even got into the
original yeah
where it's like cowboys and samurai and
everything all in the same kind of
futuristic
post-apocalyptic [ __ ]
it was hilarious it was kind of funny
you know he was caging the [ __ ] out in
it
it looked good you know but it just
yeah
yeah i couldn't really get into it it
looked like the most of the shutter
people were kind of like i think it had
three stars which usually means most
people are kind of like yeah yeah i
didn't love it yeah had the girl who
played the mummy in it she was looking
cute the mummy from [ __ ] tom cruise's
mommy
no need for me too says uh i would get
this and rhinestone cowboy mixed up when
i was younger it's funny because every
time i think about this movie that
[ __ ] rhinestone cowboy song goes even
though this is this uh movie is much
much better several hundred times better
than rhinestone cowboy
but i did see that one too as a kid
because of course i did i kind of saw
everything
but uh yeah so had you seen midnight
cowboy prior to us watching it you had
hadn't you me yeah yeah i thought you
had yeah it's just i kind of feel like
i'd seen it a bunch of times and then
i'd seen it a couple times but really
didn't get it i was uh
i think the last time i saw it i might
have been about 21 22 no no i was
probably about 24
last time i saw it
and um i didn't re i just thought it was
just kind of like a
depressing or kind of funny it starts
off kind of funny funny like buddy flick
that ends up to get being depressing at
the end
i didn't really see through the [ __ ]
psychosexual angle of it that i was
going oh okay there's a lot more to this
movie than than meets the eye you got to
think about it
you know yeah
you're like
this it's about this dude from [ __ ]
texas
who was a dishwasher
and the only thing he's got going for
himself is that he's good looking and he
looks like a [ __ ] cowboy he said he
tells people i'm not a real cowboy but i
have a real stud
yeah that's like his go-to line yeah
yeah that's his branding so yeah he has
this dream
that he's this is taking place in the
70s
he has this dream that he's going to
leave texas well 69
69. the book actually came out in 1965.
okay but the movie came out in 1960 it
looked like early 70s yeah well the same
thing same thing so
he goes to damn
he has this dream
that if he goes to texas or if he goes
to new york
he will be able to sell dick
to to all these women that love cowboys
these rich older ladies rich older
ladies right
so he gets there and actually he [ __ ]
the first woman he gets he [ __ ]
gets a jackpot you know he he probably
could have made that his girlfriend she
was already had all kinds of money but
no he's trying to sell the dick
[Laughter]
and she's like get the [ __ ] out of here
dude well then she he ends up giving her
money yeah he ends up giving her money
he gives her money and so he he [ __ ]
goes to new york and they start running
through his texas ass because he's
really nice he's too soft to be a gigolo
you know
and he falls in with this dude named
[ __ ] rizzo who they call him ratso
[ __ ] rizzo [ __ ] takes him for a
ride and sends him to a damn religious
cult it says you need management you
know
i know that i know this pimp yeah yeah
yeah it was it was a preacher okay but
he got
but ratso got twenty dollars out
okay
he sees ratso later [ __ ] you know
threatens to beat his ass but they kind
of become friends and ratso's [ __ ]
living in this abandoned apartment and
he's living in there with him and
all kinds of weird [ __ ] happens you know
[ __ ] ratso starts [ __ ] with it you
know your cowboys are gay you know
[ __ ] in new york it is kind of funny
because in new york cal at this time
probably still is that it's part of the
gay fetish thing yeah so he ends up
having to like
selling it
well first he sells it to a little
jewish kid remember that in the [ __ ]
movie theater
but then the kid didn't have any money
funny even beat him up fun fact that was
bob balaban that was the same guy that
uh directed parents
and he's he's been in a zillion things
and he's directed a zillion things yeah
yeah so all this [ __ ]
wild ass [ __ ] happened and you're like
what the hell is wrong with this dude
why is all and they every time he goes
through these [ __ ] weird moves they
kind of do a flashback of how he grew up
in texas
and it's some weird [ __ ] his mom
base his mom was hanging out with some
other chick does she like a teenager and
they
just kind of gave him over to the
grandma yeah and she never saw his mom
again
so i guess the i guess i guess his mom
was
kind of a hoe yeah now she never came
back
and uh grandma
i guess there was a sexual relationship
going on with grandma
see that's kind of i always thought that
was the implication now they do like
it's pretty straightforward that grandma
was also kind of a hoe no no shame
against hoes and uh she liked cowboy
she liked cowboys which is where he got
the where he got the cowboy thing
because there's like all these father
figures that were coming through his
life that were all kind of like these
cowboy types yeah i'm pretty sure and i
we're not the only people that have said
this i don't see it like in probably
about 20 of the reviews i read of it
some people have said is the implication
that
the grandma was sexually molesting him i
think or at least giving him approval to
a point and support it could go either
way i don't i don't think it's it's not
explicitly like laid out and i'm not
sure if it is in the book either
they show them in bed together but they
don't ever show them having sex it's
just it was just kind of uh because that
would have been something
yes she was just kind of like he he saw
her as a big security blanket you know
so
and then
he gets all these opportunities in the
movies to make girlfriends but he he
doesn't he he doesn't follow through you
know what i mean he's trying to sell it
you know instead of having a
relationship
it's [ __ ] nuts well then they show
what happened to him with his girlfriend
he had this girlfriend
who uh
[ __ ] doted on him and said crazy
annie crazy and how she was the only one
type of deal
but i think she was having sex with a
bunch of other dudes she was the town
bike yeah
and when they were making out
[ __ ] on a lover's lane type thing all
her [ __ ] spurned [ __ ] boyfriends
that she was sleeping with converge on
the car
and rape her and him yeah it's like a
gang rape yeah so and they don't show it
they don't show it but they literally
that's what happened i mean they kind of
show it but it's like in more
implication than yeah that's a flashback
and that's when he was in high school
and then when the cops show up
she because she's crazy she blamed him
for it yeah and she gets taken and put
into this island yeah now so so he's
kind of like
he the reason why he can't have a normal
relationship is because he sees it as
possible too dangerous like it's going
to be betrayal well he's never had a a
healthy relationship modeled for him
yeah right so he doesn't really know any
better and another thing too is that his
whole thing where he actually thinks
he's going to go to new york city
and be a gigolo and he's going to be
really really popular because all the
only thing he's good at is loving he
says yeah but the implication is that
crazy annie was his only girlfriend yeah
and she was taking him for a ride right
so he kind of thought that he was going
to be able to like not necessarily pull
the wool over other people's eyes but
it's like everybody was like taking
advantage of him but he didn't really
seem to be aware of it yeah it's got a
lot of weird angles all right yeah he
he gets drafted and goes to the army and
when he comes back a year later
he goes back home and grandma's gone
she's dead and he was felt and they show
him out there breaking down crying in
front of the house and it's all
abandoned
because
and he blamed her he said that she died
without telling him
yeah that's some weird [ __ ] yeah oh hey
uh i'm i'm dying over here
so that was kind of sad now yeah so he
had to become a dishwasher and he wanted
he wanted to go back and do like a i
guess the security type of blanket of
being taken care of by older women
and like i said he could have had that
but for some reason he was hell-bent on
selling it instead of [ __ ] having her
having a relationship with these women
because he could have had a relationship
with him he had money
it's crazy and he wasn't getting any
money for it they weren't paying him
much he was only asking for like 20
bucks
i was like wow that would be crazy i
mean even in 1969 yeah i kind of feel
like that's
kind of cheap so he's a failed he's
failed he's a failed
well the thing about it and like i think
zack pointed out earlier this is
actually one of the first like
mainstream gay movies where they made it
seem like like he didn't really want to
do the gay thing but he wasn't averse to
it he was gay for pay yeah like he would
do it because you know they they kind of
show a scene of him kind of going down
and walking down the you know that
district and it's like there's a lot of
like gay hustlers down there and they
have like the cowboy [ __ ] going on right
and so he does okay well i guess i'm
gonna do this because it's not working
out like with the the high-end
like older ladies yeah so he's not like
averse to it it's just like not his
first choice yeah and this is uh you
know i forgot the actor's name vaughn
john john floyd yeah and john boyce's
looking good in this too but he's in
real good shape he's young he's real
handsome he's the exact opposite of
[ __ ]
dustin hoffman's character in this
[ __ ] ratso all right ratsos is
[ __ ] broken down [ __ ] urban
scumbag in his con man and he's like not
even a good one all right petty criminal
and [ __ ] yeah and um
the weird thing happened is that
[ __ ] razzo was always making fun of
him for [ __ ] being gay for pay and
[ __ ] with him and trying and [ __ ] but
they were friends
and
rachel was getting sick
and
[ __ ] what's it what's the cowboy's
name uh [ __ ] joe buck joe yeah joe yeah
so joe says um
joe was out turning tricks
and taking the money and buying food and
trying to buy food and medicine for for
rats yeah he was a very good-hearted
person yeah so in a way
this is kind of like
a relationship this is his only
relationship that he's ever had yeah
it's like a bromance it's like a
bromance but there isn't any sex
happening yeah it's kind of sweet
actually because they're they're so
they're complete opposite yeah and it's
a weird thing this dude is not gay but
he's [ __ ]
selling it to dudes to get money to help
ratzo
well finally uh
they get [ __ ] evicted they're gonna
[ __ ] conte condemn the building
and he's got rad so [ __ ]
he says i gotta get you out of here
gotta get you out of new york he wants
to go to florida that's his dream yeah
so he's got him all to
[ __ ] radzos is showing his fantasies
about how famous he's gonna be he's
gonna be a famous cook in florida and
[ __ ] tell where you go to all the
resorts and laying by the pool and all
these old ladies
yeah it's [ __ ] funny he's the gordon
ramsay he thinks he's bored
so he's fantasizing about that and um
that and that that's that's the second
part of it is that they're trying to get
to try to get ratso out of [ __ ] new
york because he's getting sicker and
he's getting sicker well it doesn't go
to the doctor well yeah that too um but
the the thing about it is that well one
he doesn't have any money yeah uh he
lives in a condemned building he could
have gone to the emergency room though
which that was an actual building that
was condemned they actually did tear it
down after that but the inside of his
apartment i watched like a behind
behind-the-scenes documentary about this
the inside of his apartment
it was a real apartment but they
basically took the whole apartment apart
and put it back together like in a sound
stage and they said when you walked in
there it looked and smelled exactly like
a new york city like tenement building
because they took it from the building
it just wasn't in that building anymore
because it wasn't safe like to film in
there they did like the exteriors yeah
um but but yeah so he just lives in this
like shitty there's no electricity
there's no anything like that so i think
that's kind of why like he has this
dream of like going to florida because
he's like freezing his ass off all the
time and zach says uh doesn't dustin
hoffman like you know ratso does he die
of aids or something at the end no that
he does die but they don't um they're
just saying they don't say what it is i
just assumed he's like
he's well there's bad roaches in the
apartment and it was [ __ ] pretty
unsanitary in there and he was sick from
i think the beginning he might have like
pneumonia and he had a club foot yeah
and uh so he he and
they i it must have been just something
like typhus or [ __ ] you know
something that you'd normally die from
you know yeah because like i said he
didn't have any heat
i'm sure he wasn't really eating all
that much or anything any good like he
was eating a bunch of shitty food and it
was real psychological
whoever wrote this story either they saw
this happen or something they
be uh because it it it really kind of
is
kind of explores the human mind
you see
joe is taking care of rad so he rad so
[ __ ] lost control of his bladder he
[ __ ] pissed himself he was on the bus
he was so sick
so joe takes his own money and [ __ ]
goat when the bus stops
gets him on all new set of clothes and
it's all [ __ ] flower shirts like yeah
because it's like florida florida
[ __ ]
he's got him all dressed up like that
and he's [ __ ] talking to him about
how [ __ ] great florida's gonna be and
then he [ __ ] dies but he died kind of
fantasizing about florida so
and he did get there you got there
to be honest
ratso would have never made it in
florida
he he was [ __ ]
the new york city rat [ __ ] through
and through i don't think he could have
made that transition uh
well like that's kind of like the whole
point of it is that he had that dream
yeah it was kind of like either they
were just opposing it against like joe
buck dreaming that he was actually going
to go to new york city no and he was
going to be like this big famous gigolo
and make all this money and it's like
neither of them really worked out you
know what i mean but that you know like
i said they found each other and it was
just kind of like this kind of sweet
friendship that developed yeah and then
when he died he goes up and tell and
this is kind of like a turning point in
the movie that the very end [ __ ] um
well when he was buying the clothes
there was a real cute
waitress in there florida waitress you
know who's flirting with him and he's
just having like you can see that he's
already kind of getting sucked into
maybe like a normal relationship yeah
that's possible so maybe he'd gotten
through his issues yeah and when he was
telling when when he was written there
with rad so he says you know i don't
think i'm i think i'm just going to get
a job when i get back because it's it's
just being uh selling dick is too hard
i see what you i see what you did there
[Laughter]
so it wasn't going to work so and while
he said and then he died
when he was telling him that so he goes
up to the bus driver
and and uh tells him yeah he died you
know i'm [ __ ] the bus driver looks
and says well here we just cover it up
we're not going to make a big deal it's
okay there's
calming everybody down he's just sick
and um the bus driver asked him is this
is he kin to you
and he went
no
no he's not
and that's kind of how it was resolved
he wasn't related to him they weren't
married or anything it wasn't you know
and yeah he just left him on the bus
yeah it was just kind of like they were
buddies but they just
there was no future there his future was
back in florida with girls
he wasn't even gay
so what was he going to do with rats
like i said he wasn't a verse to go and
gave her pay but it wasn't really his
but no yeah preference but he was doing
that to help [ __ ] help help ratzo
because he was sick because he was dying
right but like i said that was the thing
like he was such
a good-hearted guy
and it's almost kind of like
he almost like for a little while like
made ratso a little bit of a better
person because like i said at first like
rats are just trying to [ __ ] them over
just like everybody else did nobody
cared about rats so either it was just
kind of a
symbiotic
weird relationship between the two but
it wasn't sexual it was just because
nobody cared about them yeah that's what
it was yeah they were like at the bottom
of their the barrel
yeah and they just kind of like found
now i guess there was one good one good
uh scene where him and ratso were in the
in the new york um
diner
and some proto-goths go in there and
take a picture of [ __ ] joe because he
looked good and invited him to a party
when he goes there he has a [ __ ]
fantastic time
and rizzo just he he's kind of like a
third wheel he keeps it's one of the
andy warhol parties
those are all of the andy warhol people
like andy warhol
actually helped them set up that it
actually looks like yeah his studio they
set it up like that and those are pretty
much all his friends and hangers on yeah
and they just basically just said have a
party yeah they were cool looking people
they were getting high and [ __ ] and um
joe hooks up with a real hottie she was
young
photographer wasn't she was the
photographer or was it yeah yeah yeah
artist fashion designer that was brenda
vaccaro she was in uh oh and she was
also in capricorn one yeah okay yeah she
played uh the main guy's wife yeah
rizzo's there trying to be the [ __ ]
pimp
and he [ __ ] cutting the deal and you
you know he will have sex with you you
will pay him this amount of money and
she's like oh i got to pay him
she's
[Laughter]
he could have had a relationship with
her but he didn't do it and then at the
end of that night he she gives him a
reference she sends him over to one of
her friends but she never shows and he
never said it yeah she never shows so
that was kind of the end of his uh his
[ __ ] gigolo career yeah he didn't
really do much
yeah it's you know
to be honest with you i mean even when
he did gay for pay like i said he had
that one guy that he didn't really have
sex with that guy he well not really no
it's just that it was just oral or
whatever the dude was blowing him and
that yeah and then let dudes blow it
yeah for money but then like they went
together the bathroom later and he's
like oh i don't have any money yeah and
then while all that [ __ ] well that dude
was blowing him it looked like a little
uh
like a little jewish college boy or
something was blowing him and uh with
glasses and [ __ ] book book worm type and
while he's blowing him there's some
symbolism going on behind him in the
audience was all those dudes that raped
him
oh i didn't notice that you're back
there laughing at him no i didn't notice
that yeah but it was in his mind you
know now i have to see that again yeah
louis says i always thought he died of
tuberculosis yeah oh it might have been
a bad it might he wasn't coughing that
much though tuberculosis you cough i
don't know he was caught yeah he was
coughing was he coughing up blood uh no
i don't think so but yeah he was
coughing a lot yeah it was probably
something like tb somebody it was some
medieval disease that normally wouldn't
kill you that normally wouldn't kill or
that normally like you know you'd get
treatment
you wouldn't get like in the west or you
get treated for um but like i said
that's what they were trying to say it's
like he lived in such shitty conditions
yeah yeah oracle says the movie's a dark
look at the american ideal that if you
work hard you can make money yeah i
think it's definitely that um i want to
say two of i was going to say this is
actually kind of funny
that
i think people like when you watch this
movie you so associate dustin hoffman's
character with new york city he's just
like the quintessential like new york
sleaze
and then you know jon voight's
characters this aw shucks like good old
boy from texas ironically jon voight the
actor is from new york city yeah and
from yonkers actually and uh dustin
hoffman is actually from california yes
so so that's just like acting you guys
because you would never know that like
watching this movie i don't think this
has anything to do with uh working hard
on the american dream or anything like
that though i think that's a
misconception because it's just obvious
women women don't pay for sex it's very
rare
well yeah obviously
yeah but like the fact that he actually
thought that that could happen well it
was kind of like he was imagining that
because he wanted a stable relationship
like he had with his grandmother
yeah and he just thought like he thought
it would be like a trade he'd entertain
him and they you know but like i said
it's time about reality it's well it
like i said they both characters were
you know and i think that's what that's
what she means what she's talking about
because both characters he actually
thought he was going to go make all this
money yeah you know and and ratzo
actually thought he was going to go to
florida and they were going to make this
big so it's kind of like so that's i
think that's what she means yeah it's
like a fantasy about theaters oh we'll
just work hard and we'll get enough
money to do what we want to do but
obviously that's not going to work out
gotta be within reason
yeah
uh zach said did this one win best
picture uh yes it did this was actually
uh far's under the only x-rated film to
win best picture it won three academy
awards i think best picture maybe best
director it was nominated for a [ __ ] ton
i know it won best picture though um but
yeah and it's since you know obviously
uh you put in the library congress it's
in all that kind of stuff so it's in
pretty much any
list of
best american films is gonna have this
on it and honestly like i said you know
i've seen it probably four or five times
over the years
but it's one of those ones that like
every time you watch it you pick up more
stuff you know what i mean
one of the funny parts is like
[ __ ]
he's talking to ratzo and going on about
[ __ ] how macho cowboy being a cowboy
is this and that rats and goes yeah new
york cow bearded cowboy's gay that's
just gay stuff
that's not gay that's all macho manly
you're trying to tell me you're trying
to tell me that john wayne is gay
and ratso just kind of went
she started you could see him thinking
himself yeah maybe
maybe he never thought of that he's like
maybe
it's just i just thought that was good
you know i thought that was much funny
well like i said it's funny because you
can't really stereotype gay people he
might be gay you know [ __ ] but that
was what ratso was thinking
yeah maybe
[Laughter]
but i think that went right over the
[ __ ]
top of [ __ ] joe's well that's the
thing is joe buck was just kind of like
his own stereotype well and i mean
essentially he's like a good-hearted
idiot i mean he's not super bright yeah
uh and he's really naive yeah and um
like i said his whole conception of
masculinity was cowboys
because that's every single father fig
figure that came through his
grandmother's bedroom yeah
with some kind of like cowboy so to him
cowboys were like super super manly so
he didn't really like he wasn't really
prepared to deal with the fact that in
new york city like you said that was
more of a gay thing yeah and that blew
his mind yeah like he didn't really get
it
so um yeah but like i said that's what's
so great about like all these little
details like that and honestly
this time um i picked up more of the
flashback stuff it's not there's not a
lot of flashback stuff in it but it does
kind of like uh kind of go back and
forth with him just remembering certain
things from his childhood and his youth
and stuff but
like i said i think i picked up more
this time and and i think i did pick up
more of the implication that maybe his
grandmother had molested him i kind of
feel like because maybe that's why he
associated like older women with because
at first like i think the first time i
watched it i just thought oh his grandma
was like a hoe or you know what i mean
like i said nothing against hoes but um
but i think this time i did kind of
because he did kind of associate like
older women like that with you know with
a sexual component yeah or so oracle mun
said that uh they were considering elvis
presley for [ __ ] the role of [ __ ]
jew wouldn't that have been something
not it not in 68
i don't think he would have he would no
i never would have done no even if they
would have asked him he wouldn't have
done it because like i said he was very
very conservative and then by the time
68 had rolled around
but but no he was already uh not in good
shape well actually he had a comeback
tour
yeah 69 i think he still looked okay
yeah i think he probably looked all
right
but but he you know
elvis had drug problems i don't think it
would have worked no i mean he wouldn't
have done it he'd go you know well yeah
even if he would have done it he's like
yeah it would be too sleazy for him
right yeah um
but i think john voight was the good was
a good choice he i don't think john boyd
was the first choice either i think
there was like a bunch of other ones
that they wanted but
when he came in
i think i saw like the uh the behind the
documentary they showed like part of his
um
background uh or his uh the audition
tape and basically what they did when
they wanted to audition them he actually
had to like beg his agent he's like
please please please like let me
audition for this because he really
wanted it even though they didn't really
want him like i said
so he finally gets to go in there and
what the audition was was just the
casting director whoever
um
like berating him about it's like why
the [ __ ] why are you dressed like that
why do you like and he had to like come
up with something on the fly and like be
the character and he was just like
really really good they said they really
liked the way he could come up with all
this stuff like he was almost
he was like really like sweet and
vulnerable
um but also i don't want to say arrogant
but he had like this weird confidence
you know what i mean like yeah the way
he is in the movie right and yeah and so
they really liked that juxtaposition of
character like he was obviously like
really naive and insecure but he kind of
overcame it with like this
like over-the-top like confidence like
yeah woo all right you know that he's
like that kind of thing he's also big he
was strong too so people didn't threaten
him he wasn't physically threatened by
anybody it's just any you know he had
that [ __ ]
texas [ __ ] macho
can do attitude but he did yeah
he was not street wise at all yeah and i
mean he just came across i mean he came
across as just like a good-hearted dude
he didn't come across as intimidating um
even though he was big like and he is
very tall like when they do all the
shots of him like walking the streets of
new york city he's like a head above
everybody else but he just comes across
they said they wanted him to be
and i don't even know if they wanted
this from the character because i think
he's a little bit different than the
character that's in the book
but when he came in he was just like
this very gentlemanly like everyone was
sir and ma'am and he had like these like
real southern gentlemen type manners and
they really really liked that
um that he kind of came across like that
because i kind of feel like if you had
made him
i don't know if you hadn't made him like
that like such a good-hearted character
i think it would have been easy to make
him like the butt of the joke because
obviously like i said he was kind of
naive and he just kept getting taken
advantage of and you'd be like holy crap
dude it's like get with the program like
get on the clue bus
but because he was so sweet you couldn't
get mad at it because he was just kind
of like no need for me too says i rocked
that elvis movie soundtrack you guys
reviewed a lot must be talking about
elvis and nixon oh yeah yeah that was a
great movie yeah i liked that yeah you
that and that dude did a great job as
elvis even though he doesn't look
anything like elvis but he he channeled
you believe it yeah how'd you believe
that's michael shannon i love michael
shannon like i told you he played
kuklinski also yeah in that other movie
he had you believe that he was elvis
yeah i bought it yeah but see like i
said that's that's the mark of a great
actor yeah even if you don't really look
like the person you can channel the
person so much that it doesn't even
matter and then like honestly if you do
it good enough you even start to kind of
look like the person yeah like even
though you don't at all he was hanging
out with a lot of guys from elvis's
friends from the memphis mafia so they
helped him he was asking them what was
he really like what was he really doing
you know
what was it like being around him so
and he would hang out with him in in a
[ __ ] character and they're going yeah
that's that he was just like that
you know so that's
i believe it
yeah [ __ ] funny man
doing karate for nixon and [ __ ] [ __ ]
hitting his hands
this is the tiger girl
[Laughter]
the hands of a tiger
but yeah so uh like i said this movie
when it uh originally came out
it um
was rated x yeah uh because of the gay
stuff yeah even though obviously there's
nothing in here it doesn't show anything
gay well it doesn't show anything
anything really i mean honestly there's
i think there's maybe a little bit of
nudity like female 1
but it's not yeah like by today's
standards
nothing would shock anybody i forgot to
mention something though about joe joe
killed that gay dude
that's right he did didn't he yeah i did
i totally forgot that
what a dumb thing to forget yeah yeah
that's that's kind of significant he
killed that gay dude to get the money to
get um to get rizzo out of town yeah
even though he said he wanted to die
so i don't know remember he said his
life was miserable please kill me you
know i want to die and whatever
yeah that was sounds pretty weird he
thought he was calling the cops and he
[ __ ]
beat him to death with the phone yeah
that's right so uh oh [ __ ] forget
that joe was [ __ ]
would have been [ __ ] running from a
second-degree murder charge true yeah
yeah isn't it weird i had totally
forgotten yeah it was because he's
likable yeah but you don't realize that
he he murdered that dude yeah
which you know to save rizzo and it
didn't work rizzo died anyway yeah
it's like that's what i mean yeah it's
like it's a tragic movie yeah but
i mean it's grim and it's a bummer but
somehow
it doesn't
i don't know it's weird it's one of
those movies that it's like it's it
doesn't really make you sad to watch it
i mean a little bit maybe
he was so kind of dumb and
happy-go-lucky he forgot that he did
that
yeah
he was just kind of like a well [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but yeah that well that just goes to
show that like he actually did have like
um
you know like i said he didn't come
across as intimidating but like he
totally could be that way yeah if
circumstances yeah correct yeah [ __ ]
rats i was like what happened to that
man did you kill that man and then he
goes i won't talk about it yeah that's
all he said and that was like the end of
it yeah
that's crazy
yeah i totally forgot about that yeah
but i just i it's funny to me though
that like i said that this was rated x
in 1969 and i know that this was even
before like you know there
it wasn't like considered a porn reading
but because of all the gay stuff
even though it doesn't show anything
everything's implication that they would
rate it that and that was the only
reason because like i said there wasn't
anything else in there it wasn't super
violent it wasn't there was no other
nudity really
or anything like that so that's just
like really funny but i think like
obviously later on it's rated r now
because
obviously it is um you know it's
not it's not shocking by today's
standards but it's pretty shocking by
the 1969 standards for sure but
honestly i think i'd like to read the
book
at some stage
i think it was interesting just from uh
the psychological elements in it like
why is this dude doing this and then
they show a flashback
yeah that kind of like explains what his
thinking is
of why he's doing that
i mean it's a great film like i said
it's i would call it's a drama i guess
it's like a buddy film more than
anything because like the friendship is
sort of at the heart of it um
but you know like i said there's a lot
of other stuff going on in it and even
though it's
the framework of it like when you say
like what the plot is it sounds like
super grim and depressing which it is
but
i don't know i guess because jon
voight's character is just so sunny all
the time that it doesn't come across
like that
even though a bunch of sad stuff happens
i don't know it's really weird it's hard
to explain i don't like it doesn't the
movie doesn't bum me out even though
it's sad
okay if that makes any sense
and i don't know and i don't know if
it's just because it has funny [ __ ] in
it too or i don't really know why but it
just it doesn't make me sad it's just a
buddy flick gone wrong
yeah
yeah sort of
kind of like a sl i guess like a slice
of life and like i said it kind of makes
it kind of makes you wonder if whoever
wrote this wrote that book knew knew
somebody that went through that somebody
knew somebody like that
they might have i mean like i said if i
ever read the book i'll let you know but
uh yeah i think i would uh like to read
that at some point and see how much it
differs i think it's different a little
bit particularly the job character but
all right uh okay so we have anything
else we need to talk about all right so
we will be back tomorrow and we'll be
discussing the eyes of laura mars
because if we watched that last night
and tom had never seen it i'd seen it a
bunch of times but that was free on
amazon wouldn't it uh yeah it's on
amazon or hulu i can't remember i think
it's amazon prime but if you have amazon
prime like you can watch it on there but
yeah i hadn't i hadn't seen it i saw it
a bunch of times on cable back in the
80s but i uh yeah i hadn't seen it since
then
john carpenter flick
yeah he didn't direct it but he wrote he
wrote the screenplay which i had totally
forgotten about yeah and i was like oh
that's why this is like a jailer movie
then yeah but uh yeah but yeah so we'll
be talking about that tomorrow at about
three o'clock hopefully our connection
holds up it held up this time i guess we
just needed to restart the router which
is kind of a pain but yeah thanks
everybody for dropping by have a good
rest of your afternoon and we will see
you guys again tomorrow